okay guys i'm wearing sunglasses today
because uh the future is bright
um you know
in case you didn't know that's a change
yeah
yeah you think the opposite based on
everything it's all in the way you look
at it you know it's all in the way you
look at it and so today
in offering uh this new perspective that
i'm bringing to the 131st chord or
digital podcast usually i play guitar
but i want to offer you guys a choice
today
i have guitar
and i also have a reading from the tao
to ching yeah let's do the reading i
think that's yeah i think it's unanimous
over here
all right exactly what tao has to say
all right let's see what the top so this
is an ancient chinese manuscript uh well
kind of like a proverbial manuscript
let me find a good one
mm-hmm
here we go i'm just gonna thumb through
it
here we go are you ready
governing a large country is like frying
a small fish
you spoil it with too much poking
center your country in the tao and evil
will have no power
not that it isn't there
but you'll be able to step out of its
way
give evil nothing to oppose and it will
disappear by itself
this is the tao
that's interesting
it's
i love that episode the mandalorian
that's cool yeah it's saying if you
don't
bother evil it will just go away
well
i think you're missing i think you're
missing a little bit yeah of it of the
of the yeah one more
one does it let evil destroy itself with
its own momentum like that kind of thing
pretty pretty much that's more like art
of war but yeah
that's pretty much the idea
um it's not that it isn't there it's
that you won't be subjected to its power
you won't be poking it in the way of the
tao yeah
yeah
anyways i'm not going to be not going to
do that ancient chinese philosophy but
there's a lot of good stuff in that book
um
anyway wow what am i talking about guys
look at what's going on we've got a new
person in the quarter cast yeah what's
up
sam gorski
yeah no seriously uh i'm super excited
uh because today uh fenner rockliffe
ladies and gentlemen has joined us
uh for a corridor cast but more than
that he's joined us for effects
videos everything good times good times
some of them cgi's yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's joined us for life
yeah for life
actually yeah
clint says that he left but actually
he's hitting him
i signed the blood contract so i'm i'm
okay yeah right now i think
yeah yeah there's no really there's no
real leaving corridor
yeah once you're in yeah
well yeah basically hey
i think that's a good way to put it well
though the reason it's not because of
anything evil or bad it's because of
these friendships that we create here
a lifetime
oh wow
nothing to do with cages or anything
what chinese proverb is that
yeah is that a chinese prophet
i don't know um so anyway i thought it
would be fun to uh
bring bring you on fenner uh get a
chance to uh for the for the croutons to
get to know you and you know kind of
talk about
what you're into what we're excited
about this year and uh and just yeah get
get to know you a little bit
sweet uh you got what do you want to
know what do you want to know oh how
would like i think we should start it
off real simple here all right so okay
we make videos we do v fix blah blah
blah okay
so
maybe in your own words why don't you
explain to us and everyone listening
uh like what you did before you got here
that makes
you a person that we should make videos
with you know like like you you
obviously
have a visual effects background but for
people
who don't know you yet like what what
are you what have you been up to or like
what are you into or
you know where where have you done vfx
before yeah i mean like probably a lot
of people watching the cast like i
started doing vfx watching corridor and
freddie w way back in the day it's like
how i got into vfx
um
like back in high school just doing that
um and yeah it was something like i
remember the very first like comb shot i
did was like a freddy w muzzle flash
tutorial
and i was like oh man i can i can make a
muzzle flash on a gun that's the
craziest thing in the world which i feel
like is probably a lot of people's
stories that are in vfx like it um
i
ended up like going to a really awesome
vfx school called think tank training
center
uh which is located in north vancouver
and canada um and it was it was amazing
like it's such a it was such a great
experience you kind of learn a little
bit of everything like animation rigging
uh they did like life drawing actual
clay sculpting as well so you'd go like
do a clay sculpting class and then go do
zbrush right after it which was really
cool that's cool yeah so it was i mean
it was kind of nice you learned a little
bit of everything
um but the first first semester you
don't learn any sort of compositing
which uh you know kind of all through
high school i've been doing like little
videos with my friends super super
inspired by corridor stuff just like
running around the neighborhood with
airsoft guns having muzzle flashes and
stuff
um and then i was kind of once i got to
the school i was kind of like oh man
this this isn't really what i thought it
would be
because there was no comp class uh
semester two
uh i think it was like day two or
something they actually did like the
intro to compositing it was the first
time i opened nuke
and then our teacher was like here's uh
action essentials or whatever i was like
oh sweet this is why i'm at the school
yeah
yeah those free asset packs yeah for
real for real
and so after that yeah i ended up just
kind of going full tilt into comp i
still kept doing the other classes but i
kind of got to a point where i was like
okay clay sculpting maybe isn't a career
for me
um
yeah and then from there
basically
i had a really
really cool mentor at the school
and he basically hooked me up with one
of his best friends from childhood who
was actually starting
this really small comp based vfx studio
called cbd vfx
um
and i got just a random call from this
number and the guy was like yo come work
for me
and so i went in for an interview and
their office at the time it was there
was like four people working there and
it was literally two janitor's closets
that they converted into like a studio
um
and it was it was cool because i had
another interview lined up that day at a
big studio
that'll remain nameless for now
um and basically the dude chris chris
van dijk who's amazing he's my mentor in
the industry he basically was like
come to interview with us first then go
to yours went to the big studio
interview walked out of it called him
right away and i was like hey can i come
work with you guys
because i got a better vibe from the
janitor's closet in the big ass board
room
why was that why was that
it was honestly one
specific thing like when i walked into
the interview uh at the little janitor's
closet studio they were basically like
sweet you're real sucks like
yeah they were like your real sucks but
we can uh make it better like you can
learn how to do vfx here and you'll be
working as part of the team
um the big studio i went to
they basically like
put it on a big projector screen in the
boardroom barely even looked at it and
they're like yeah amazing work great
stuff great and i knew my real [ __ ] like
it was like
work in progress um
and like it was a lot of like final
underscore version 32. yeah yeah uh and
then the guy was like yeah you know
you'll be fine a monkey could do this
job oh thanks yeah so that's i was like
oh okay i probably probably don't want
to work there
um
so yeah i ended up working with the guys
at cbd vfx and they were amazing i
learned so much there it was incredible
i worked there for a number of years
until the studio was acquired by a
larger studio
um ended up working there for a while
and then
kind of during covid was starting to
feel like it was time for a change and i
saw your guys video for the the we're
hiring and i was like man i should just
like i've always you know i've always
loved corridor it's it literally is the
reason i work in vfx and i was like man
i'm just gonna like take a flyer on this
i'll send in a real
um didn't hear anything back for months
so i was like i didn't get it as much
which was fine that's just how we do it
yeah which was totally all good and then
eventually heard back and i was like oh
my god came down for that visit
um
during this i guess it was last summer
or something and uh nico and i worked on
this yeah that's when we did the the the
uh x-wing yeah yeah yeah that star wars
video which was super interesting yeah
it was crazy to me because like you know
it all happened during covet and i'd
been working from home for like two
years so that was like my first time
being back in a studio environment which
felt amazing like so i was like oh my
god human beings yes yes touch my hand
which was amazing um and yeah and then
so kind of after that week i was like uh
holy like i gotta
i think i gotta make a change uh with my
career and kind of get back to why i got
into
vfx was because i wanted to make films
not just work on films you know
um
and so that's when you know we kind of
moved ahead with things and i'm from
canada originally so we had to start to
look into a visa process which was
definitely a process jake and i were
working out
dude a long time um yeah it was wild
that's the first time i've ever had to
do anything like that and it was it was
cool to see like hey this is actually
there's a process for this and like you
know you can actually like
be a little you know a little cord or
digital like trying to bring somebody in
from another country yeah um and that
was a big deal for us too like uh
it was months in the making um because
we had to they make you compile
like a whole
presentation of documents um because you
know effectively like you have to
the burden of proof is on you you know
to prove that like
okay you're bringing somebody in okay
what are they and there's certain types
and are the type we were applying for
was like okay
fenner's got extraordinary abilities and
talents
i know it must be very validating in a
way where it's like it's like it's like
hey you want to make some videos
together it's like no first we have to
convince the government that you are
worthy
of being part of your company so so we
drove down from vancouver uh my
girlfriend and i and it was i was so
stressed about the border crossing
because like i actually i talked to
chris van dyke who my mentor and he had
gone down and done the same thing when
he worked at ilm san francisco and he
was like i was like how'd it go for you
he's like oh i didn't get in they they
turned me around at the border and i was
like what that was i am like what like
what are you talking about he's like
yeah good luck really
why did they turn them around they were
like ah we don't know like if this is
legit like whatever are they really
extraordinary effects was basically
they're like are you really an
outstanding alien funny wait a second
hold on hold on wait can i i made sure
ours was approved yeah before i crossed
into canada at the border there yeah
from washington uh to vancouver with
this is like
2008 you know was we because we shot
like this low-budget movie up there that
year so like i was pretty young i was
like 22 23 maybe um
but we had like like my old car it's
like this little ford focus
packed to the brim with like computers
and pcs and stuff like you look at the
car from the outside and you see like
the inside of a pc case because it's
missing like the panel so you're like
literally looking at a bunch of computer
parts we drive up there and we're at the
border and like what are you guys coming
in here for we're like uh
camping you know just gonna camp and
like
chill
like you look at the back it's just like
binders and like pcs stacked onto each
other and the guys they're like huh okay
let's look through their thing and so
they opened it up and uh they found like
an uh
wait no they didn't find the airsoft
guns so yeah they didn't find the
airsoft guns because obviously we're
shooting a movie
but that was like the most
nerve-wracking part was like
thankfully we had piled enough pcs to
hide the airsoft guns
but still camping i guess
worked
welcome to the cool section of the
podcast where i tell you about the
coolest tool that we use here at
corridor digital courtesy of today's
sponsor storyblocks
wait wait wait jake what makes storybox
so special well
i thought you'd never ask reason number
one storybox has a virtually unlimited
library of all kinds of stock assets
including but not limited to high
quality 4k b-roll images
audio
motion graphics after effects templates
and more and every time you go on there
there's something new and different so
it is like a virtually unlimited library
and that's awesome for what we do reason
number two storyblocks has an unlimited
all-access plan that gives us well
unlimited all access to their assets
that allows us to download as much as we
want and use it in whatever we want for
whatever purposes that includes
commercial work that includes personal
work that includes work we put on
youtube anything we need it for it's all
that sweet sweet royalty free they also
have an enterprise plan if you're part
of a team and you want to get that go
and talk to your team leader you can get
your whole team hooked up with story
blocks you're gonna need a stock asset
source if you are serious about creating
so we use storyblocks we highly
recommend it and if you guys are
interested in getting started for
yourself head on over to storyblocks.com
corridor cast to get started or just
click that link in the description below
that's storyblocks.comcast
thanks for joining me on jake's cool
integration corner and now i'm going to
turn around and get back onto this
podcast
later
yeah it was it was it was so stressful
like i was like oh i'm not gonna get in
like i totally had in my head and rolled
up and the border security guard guy
that was checked he was so chill he's
like what are you doing i was like oh
i'm going down uh this job like where
can the effects i guess he knew what vfx
was and i said
like uh i talked about like this stunt
artist react and he was like oh that's
so sick like really dude welcome to
america he was like
[Laughter]
kind of visa immigration area and then
he ended up i guess they do like
i don't know like they swap off their
shifts or whatever and then so he ended
up being inside and sitting next to the
guy that was doing my immigration thing
and he like sat down next when he's like
watch out bro this guy's gonna be famous
this guy is extraordinary i'm not even
joking they were like fist bumping i was
like i was like what is going on here
and they're like welcome america bro
like oh my gosh
not at all what i expected it was it was
excellent it was a nice uh very warm
welcome to the united states that's
great it seriously i was like hell yeah
it's funny because i i'm a green card
holder so i'm like a what's known as a
permanent resident uh so i'm not a
citizen and i lost my green card but
still went to travel to england uh not
too long before i started working here
and uh i thought it would be fine
because i assumed they had like a
digitized system to keep track of me in
some way shape or form oh my god but
they don't
and so as i'm trying to get back into
the country from london i get stopped by
the people who work at the airport and
then they go and get a representative
who doesn't have a name he's a
representative from america who's only
known by a number
and he comes out and he gives me a very
stern talking to he says i'm going to be
honest
i don't know if you're going home today
he didn't whisper it but it felt like he
did and so he goes back behind the
scenes calls the consulate or i don't
know whatever the heck calls friggin the
president and uh comes back out and he
was like no joke no nonsense absolutely
stone cold terrifying and he's like i
got you in but i'm not doing this again
wow and that was like and i remember
thinking i was for i was alone for like
45 minutes thinking okay well i got to
figure out how i'm going to live in
england now because and i remember being
so scared because
that's like i'm trapped in england it's
like no i have to
i'm not coming back you know i've heard
horror stories of that where you just
don't get back in and i was just about
to start working here and i was like
well that sucks
it's a rough start
yeah can i work remote like is that
funny what's that pharmacy we're called
like boots or whatever boo yeah you're
like halfway through an application like
[ __ ]
yeah so i like i like your experience
better that's all it was honestly it was
like it made such a difference like it's
man it was so
i mean the whole visa process jake and i
went through so much and then even like
a few days before i was actually driving
down i looked at the actual
documentation we had and it's like this
is not a visa you cannot use this and
like jake had mentioned he's like
they'll probably just stamp it at the
border but maybe make sure and so i
spent like four hours yeah calling
different like government offices in
canada in the states and no one could
give me an answer on whether i'd
actually be like let through the border
uh so like i ended up going like the us
consulate and everything and they
finally someone was like yeah you'll be
fine don't worry okay but then even then
i was still i was still freaking out
about getting in but yeah
yeah there are it's it is very confusing
and then they yeah they send you they
approve the visa
and the visa is
it's it's got the the name of the visa
the like number of the
that they give you
and it's got everything but then it says
like this is not a visa yeah but it's
literally called a visa at the top of
the document
and and but but that's because i think
because the actual visa
is the stamp that they give you super
official that's yeah that's the actual
visa so i did look it up before
we before and i checked the the
government's websites to like verify
that it had gone through and not just
like trust the lawyers and and all that
stuff but yeah i
i think that's why they put that on
there yeah um
and and so
yeah but i could see you know like it
could be it could be nerve-wracking
there's also a lot of weird
um
like for for example for some daca
recipients or like dreamer recipients
and things like that i've heard that
when they
if if they are about to
like start the process of getting
citizenship or they're going to get
citizenship they have to
one of the rules one of the one of the
and i get why this rule is in place but
one of the rules that does shouldn't
apply in this situation for like
dreamers which i don't know if you guys
know what dreamers are but it's like
people who were taken up here by their
parents
when they were under the age of uh when
they were minors and they didn't have a
choice in whether or not they could go
so they ended up in a country illegally
that they didn't have a choice to enter
um so the question is like well should
these people be citizens
and so but one of the processes is that
you cannot become a citizen if you enter
the united states illegally
uh
and and it's something like there's a
10-year rule where if it's like found
that you've entered
illegally and then you know yada yada or
like have overstayed or whatever there's
like a 10-year ban rule
and so what these people have to do is
they have to go
because they didn't enter the country
legally technically
they have to go and then
like re-enter
this they have to leave the country and
then re-enter just so that there's like
a stamp that says like okay you entered
the country legally
and the only stamps that exist are
outside the border
no no
you can't get the stamp unless you enter
unless your feet leave that's that's
funny yeah i was just about to commend
the stamp i'm like i was about to like
go on a tangent about electronic
signatures and missing like that you
know process but
i don't know now i'm like
this took a dark turn yeah stamp is very
serious
yeah the stamp is very serious yeah
but anyway uh i'm glad man i'm glad that
you you basically had a party with the
border it was
i'm not even joking it was so funny and
they they toss you a beer on your way
out or whatever it seriously felt like
that like a budweiser american flag
that wrapped me in an american flag put
you in a truck yeah get out of here
get out of here
[Laughter]
yeah
it was great man it was a great
experience um yeah it was you know it i
it was weird too because it was right
around the time like canada was rolling
back like
some of the covid laws and stuff so it's
like you didn't need to get tested off
the land border but you did it at the
like get it it was a lot easier to uh
get through the border and immigrate
this time around than it was like that
initial visit during the summer like
flying from canada that was like i
almost almost didn't make the flight
because the guy didn't understand what
vfx was again and yeah you needed like a
temp visa to just do the the week here
no not even it was just like you know
say what you're traveling for i was like
oh it's for a job interview which maybe
wasn't the best idea i should have said
leisure or whatever but i mean it was
the truth and
yeah those things are intimidating oh so
yeah it's been it's been more
obviously it's been a lot more rigid uh
up up in canada too in terms of like
just
some of the coveted protocols and stuff
like
so i assume that that
yeah that's uh that's been
lingering a lot longer and like you know
what you can and can't do and where you
can and can't go yeah and all that stuff
yeah this at this point i think they're
pretty much in in british columbia at
least where i'm from it's pretty much
like i think they dropped like mask
mandate i think they're rolling back
vaccine mandates all that stuff but yeah
it was um it was really interesting like
i mean cove it was just such a bizarre
time like working from home was
i think such a yeah crazy shift for the
entire vfx industry because you know the
excuse had always been from studios like
marvel and all that they're like well
security wise we can't do that and now
it's like
yeah you can like
uh like
during covet
essentially during the process of like
coming to work here at quarter i ended
up actually signing a contract with weta
digital which was amazing uh and working
for them remote like i'd hoped to maybe
be able to get over new zealand at some
point but
it was again so weird with how they had
handled kovid like they were like we're
totally open like whatever and then
i guess no one was vaccinated because
they were yeah well they had a little
walled garden and then like one little
bug
got in and then so it was so funny
because we were like you know i was
finishing up my contract there and i was
like i was out of the bar with my
friends last night and they're all like
we're in lockdown we can't leave the
house and i'm like man it's
such a big can't even open the windows
yeah right
that's brutal that the bugs might get in
yeah it's just what was that
like because that was the big thing we
we we
met last summer and then you're like
this sounds cool but there's one last
thing i got to do and we're like what's
that
work for the top
vfx
house
in the entire world yeah just real quick
yeah it's really quick
you guys are like yeah i sound sick
right now we all like
we all we all left and you look up out
the windows and we all like look down
and we nod at you like
this is the right thing to do
uh no but seriously how was that because
like we i i was i'm still very curious
like what what is that process like like
what were like i mean obviously probably
ndas or whatever but you know what what
was that like yeah it was man it was it
was really amazing it's um
i i definitely think you kind of
i think it loses a bit of the magic of
going to wedda by staying in your living
room yeah yeah i know you don't get to
be like hey uh on my lunch break can i
do a cool tour of like the model shop or
whatever yeah quick tour of peter
jackson yeah exactly right
now just in there just waiting for
people to look at him
[Laughter]
chilling
[Laughter]
yeah it was i mean it was so cool it was
amazing to get to go to a studio like
that and see like their pipeline is so
so developed and so like they've got it
so dialed it was it was an incredible
experience i got to work on some really
cool projects there um i
can i think i'm allowed to say i worked
on hawkeye and peacemaker which were two
really fun ones and then another project
that's still working oh
yeah um but it was amazing it was uh the
team like everyone i met there was super
nice and i mean met remotely but you
still kind of get a
get a vibe from people and everyone's
like so good at what they do there did
you work on any of the shots that are on
that vfx breakdown for hawkeye they just
released uh
it's the bridge yeah we did the whole
bridge sequence um damn yeah yeah wait a
second
yeah for the next video
wait is this turning into the game
i'm being super serious like like that
would be the funniest like craziest
episode ever was like today we're doing
we have a special guest
here's fenner
he worked on a bunch of marvel movies
and he's also working with us
sorry
too excited
yeah it was a it was crazy that was so
cool yeah it was my it was my first day
like they they do the most amazing
onboarding there is insane they
literally you walk in day one we'll walk
in you log into your computer day one
and they're like what's up kid and
they're like here's two weeks of just
learning like awesome you're gonna spend
they they work like 50 hour weeks as
their standard there they're like you're
gonna learn for 50 hours a week for two
weeks so you basically just it's really
funny because i was worried going in
there i was like oh man i gotta like
brush up on my deep compositing and
stuff because they're their whole setup
and nuke is all deep like all the
remnants which is incredible they um
because they really they develop that
yeah technology and like really deep
compositing is uh like
it's like uh some like weird like world
space kind of based
yeah kind of stuff yeah the basically
like the way i try to explain it is
basically like think of your you're
getting a render out of i don't know my
v-ray or something uh
basically each pixel has like
not depth info but uh deep data so you
can basically be like if i want to place
a 2d element in 3d space like on a card
or something it's just automatically
held out by that 2d image yes every like
pixel has like it's it's like locked
like world data yeah and so you can
basically within nuke uh using like
proprietary nuke tools and what i have
they're amazing like sweet as well
um you can basically just like view your
scene in 3d from a 2d image as well does
it look almost like a point cloud yeah
it's like a super dense point cloud
basically it's so cool that's pretty
sweet yeah that's pretty sweet because
that's the like you know i guess it's
time to nerd out on vfx um but like that
that's for me anyways you know you
there's a thing called like a z depth
pass obviously you render that out and
that's like a black and white image it
looks you know when you look at it it's
like oh here's a foggy environment yeah
um
but it's cool you can use it for like
depth of field all that stuff but the
problem is that it's locked relative to
the camera so if the camera like pushes
through a scene
like the edge of that fog will push with
it and so
you can do a lot of stuff with that but
when you actually have
the position of every pixel
in your image
like it's like the same as having your
entire shot 3d tracked and having a zdf
pass and then being able to apply
way more complex things like actual true
like volumetrics and fog and yeah and
literally compositing into the depth of
the render yeah yeah it's so incredible
it's like it was it's so cool and like
going in there that's they have their
whole training program and like i was
trying to brush up my deep before and
then basically day one they're like
forget everything you've ever learned
about nuke we have our own face yeah so
that's yeah that's the thing that
intrigues me is the proprietary software
at what uh yeah like i don't know how
much you can talk about it but probably
not at all but but just the experience
of like for example when i think of deep
compositing i've never done it i've like
geeked out about it but never like
actually done it and i just wonder that
must be the heaviest workflow for you
know it's bad enough with like a crypto
mat or you know multi multiple passes
wrapped up in one exr file
but deep just feels like it's gonna be
this chug monster that you'd have to be
really a lot of pre-comping set up for
yeah
so yeah like what was it like working
with their tools without you know
obviously it was it was amazing like
that the two weeks of training you get
you're basically you know starting from
the ground up with like relearning their
comport flow and it's like it was
totally different from anything i've
ever been used to before because they're
it's like such a rigid pipeline and
i think it was kind of cool going in
there from a small studio experience
because there was like
you know the first shot they gave me was
um on that bridge sequence the car chase
thing in hawkeye uh which was super cool
i was like right out of the gate i was
like okay this is a cool shot like holy
crap like these people fighting between
two moving cars on like the uh i think
the manhattan bridge or whatever
and it's like all the renders just
looked awesome but then there's like one
small tweak during the dailies review
and they're like oh we'll have to send
that back to lighting it'll be like
render will be ready next week and i was
like
just i could tweak tweak it like
and it's really funny when you like the
experience of the big studio is like
it's so
everything's so dialed in that it's like
there wasn't a ton of room for creative
input um
because it's kind of just like hey it
looks good if you need something tweaked
we'll go to a different department but i
actually
i think that's kind of a negative
side of those big studios because you're
so like
it limits your creativity so much and
limits like the problem-solving side of
the effects which is kind of what vfx is
it's just like okay how can i use all
these different software packages to get
this shot done so yeah there's a lot of
fun and not knowing how to do something
and finding a way i totally agree yeah
yeah i mean that's the thing we talk
about a lot too on
you know like the vfx artist show
because
like so much of the stuff we cover up
until
basically like the early 90s
i mean there's still some stuff from
like you know until like maybe the early
2000s but
generally anytime you wanted to create a
cool effect it was all about ingenuity
it was always like here's something
we're trying to do
and
there's not like a
there's not a
way to do it
so to speak you have to invent a way to
do it and
like when it came to not like with
visual effects
um it's basically like all right we want
a monster
and we wanted to run around and do this
xyz thing and so it's like
cool all right yeah we can do that it's
like there's no like obviously there's
like plenty of
research artists do when it comes to
like shading and like
animation tricks and stuff like that to
improve it but you know it's it's very
frequently that
okay yeah yeah model monster put some
bones on it here we go
yeah so is that something where when you
get
you know your workload
there's already like a very
structured idea of what the final image
is to look like
yeah totally um like it's pretty common
in the industry now that you kind of go
through like a previz phase where you
know it's pretty well done and then like
big studios still do like post vis as
well so at that point it's like it
pretty much looks like a play blast of
the shot
and so you're like okay sweet i just
matched to that and then
i mean the thing with weta is like the
lighting renders i was getting i was
like oh man i feel like i don't really
even need to comp this like obviously
you still go in there and try to you
know give the shot your love and make it
your special little baby every shot but
there's some of them that are just like
especially once you've like templated
out that nuke script it was literally
like
swap in your new render and hit
render and you're like all right i guess
i'll go
grab some
drink or something it's pretty
impressive that they even i mean to have
such a dialed in pipeline like yeah
which you'd have to imagine
so many high-end projects yeah they do
it as a as a exercise in like
ingenuity organization and
like use of tools man
it is pretty incredible yeah it's i mean
nothing nothing but good things to say
about my time there it was a lot of work
like there are i mean it's just the
reality in the vfx industry there's
going to be like some crazy overtime
depending on the project so it was
definitely a lot of hours
um but
you know i i knew that going into it and
i kind of committed to like well i'm
working from home anyways i'm just going
to be this little vfx hermit for a while
which was it's funny you told me that
before you started you're like
i'm going to work 70 hours a week and
i'm just going to do that for six months
and learn as much as i can
and yeah yeah we were like yes dude do
it yeah that sounds awesome that's
pretty much what happened
yeah it was uh it was pretty like pretty
funny during one of the like kind of
crunch periods on one of the projects i
like grew my beard out too so i was like
i just look like it's like actual like
hermit man
it was consuming you yeah it was just
yeah but i mean you haven't come from
that now you've tasted the manna from
heaven those those those tools built
just for the gods yeah and coming back
out of that now
i mean do you miss them like
you know what's out i don't know what's
out there i mean i live in bliss
honestly that was the thing that was
most attractive about coming to quarter
was getting back to that like small
studio environment of like hey let's
just make some cool stuff like
uh
you know
the figuring out how to do it like i
don't know when we were when i was down
here visiting and just talking about the
son of a dungeon stuff and like from
what i'd heard from
um like listening to the podcast before
i was like
and that sounds super cool like
basically doing your like
own like indie virtual production setup
and it looks good and it works and it's
like
you know just the idea of like i said
before getting back to making films
rather than working on films like
it was i mean i went and saw the new the
batman the other day and watching the
vfx credits for that and one of the
studios rolled up and zero artist
credits
i was like
oh that sucks like it is that's the
reality of the industry it's such a
machine wow and it's like yeah you know
those are artists that are probably
working overtime like really really
giving it and putting like a lot of work
into the project and then to not even
get a credit like not a single artist
credit for the whole studio i was like
just the studio name yeah i was like oh
that's yeah it really sucks yeah and you
you definitely i mean
again i love dweta but there's
definitely you do get that aspect of
like oh i'm such a
small fish in such a large vfx pawn yeah
yeah and i think it yeah it really just
comes down to
like what is your
process for filmmaking and obviously you
have a huge multi-million dollar
production
you're gonna previous the crap out of it
you're gonna figure out the exact timing
and the exact framing and exact
everything of every shot in your film
before anyone actually starts trying to
make it look good but then you change it
all last minute once it looks good and
then they change it all yeah yeah but
like even still it's just that concept
of like
oh no no we did all the work someone
else did all the work they figured out
the shot they did all the stuff all
you're doing is just like
you know putting some icing on it you
know and that that that's how it comes
off to me when i
like it's maybe it's a little cynical i
suppose but i i but it versus you know
the smaller version which is like hey
look we're making some shots what should
they be yeah yeah what should this look
like
what should like you know in in it's
always that's usually the start of the
conversation all the all the time with
that yeah i think it's so much more
validating and rewarding to be like oh
yeah we shot that tracked it modeled
that thing compt it like did this like
sound design like you know having
the creative input on it and i think
that's what i was missing so much and
what was like the reason i started doing
vfx in the first place was like i wanted
to make these little
dumb short films with my friends like
running around shooting each other with
their soft guns so i'm like
sweet like yeah the joy the joy for me
too is also in the the creative aspect
of it yeah i remember when i was i was
younger i was a little child actor and
the reason i got into acting was because
i thought that the actors controlled the
whole movie because they're the only
ones that i saw so i was like oh if i
become an actor then i get to make a
movie and then when i started doing it i
was like being told exactly what to do
and not to stray from it and then i saw
the guy telling me what to do and i said
what do you do because i want to do that
and that was directing and then you
start to like oh okay hold on a second
where's the creature where's the
creative outlet here jordan you know
when you're a kid do you have a little
british accent
i did i did i did yeah i did i i did a
dance again
mommy please don't uh and i lost it when
i was like five and then we had another
british kid visit
uh
he became my arch nemesis now i'm
kidding but i i heard him speak and then
i dueling children yes he said hello
jordan and i heard him playing pranks on
you i heard him speak and then
recognized in myself that i no longer
had the accent this is the first moment
i became like self-aware
and i remember just openly weeping oh i
didn't hide it i openly wept and i was
comforted by some lovely older woman i
don't remember who it was
i could understand being openly openly
weeping if you lose a british accent
it's it's just
it just sounds cooler yeah yeah as far
as
accents
it's a good one i had a northern english
accent though so like kind of near near
liverpool oh liverpool okay so be a bit
more like abrasive yeah
lovely boy
i don't need to be insulting but it's
like there's northern ireland has a very
particular accent though
it's it's irish
that's all it sounds
like
it's just it's just amazing to me like
how you go literally like an hour in one
direction and people speak totally
differently in terms of their accents
it's crazy i almost equate it to
go from la to pasadena
and it's a completely different dialect
almost it's it's one of the wildest
things and i think it's because
how long they've been there i guess and
before the old horse and buggy they were
basically different countries if you're
30 miles away i'm never going to see you
you don't exist to me like if you go far
enough in one direction they literally
speak a different language called like
welsh well yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah you go out to the desert here
in california island i literally just
like the size of illinois
yeah yeah it's crazy yeah that's so
crazy but yeah it's definitely it is
that historical holdover mm-hmm that's
cool that's pretty sweet well prior to
prior to
no i'm supposed to know french it's
canada's second language and i was i
guess well you're also from western
canada
i also got kicked out of french class
that's the problem
canada's second language
the priorities are clear yeah
do you i had a friend who was quebecois
why did you get kicked out uh
i was poor french or a little bit like
poor french and also it was it was like
the part in my french kind of thing
man i was such a i was such a bad
student like i would just i would would
make her name was madame oh i would make
the madame's life just what was her name
no but she was french yeah wow pranks
yeah i just i made her life horrible and
i didn't didn't blame her for kicking me
out of the class it was like principles
that's when you know you were bad when
you say i don't blame them i really
don't know like man it's so like so much
regret i i ended up like uh
ended up teaching vfx like after school
and stuff for a couple years uh just
before moving down here and you know
it's different because the students for
the most part like adults but even then
you're still like
oh man teaching is brutal yeah it's so
hard
yeah you know
this is like you know grown adults where
they're for the most part respectful but
sometimes would like talk back or
something and you're like
oh god
yeah like yeah yeah i feel like yeah the
high school years are probably the
toughest because your limbs are longer
than your attention span and you just
got all these like gangly oh i was the
gangliest child like i feel like i still
am but i was like gangle to the max like
you're angloid as well yeah i also was a
gangloid yeah i like yeah i was always
like very tall growing up like just shot
up like a bean pole but i was like so
skinny and like i was loud and just like
it's it's such an odd period of time too
because you're like you're six foot two
but you weigh about 85 pounds soaking
wet yeah and you still want to watch
cartoons it's the strangest like
i don't know what to do with myself mom
yeah leave me
alone
upstairs so weird like
uh like i remember i used to
like during the summers my dad was a
commercial salmon fisherman which i feel
like is very canadian that's like the
most canadian thing yeah
it's been in my family for generations
but i used to go that was my summer job
is i would go commercial salmon fishing
with him and so cool i would be like 16
and we'd be up in these like northern
towns we'd go as far like north as
alaska and stuff
um
and i remember going to like these pubs
and stuff and being like 16 and they're
like well you're like six foot something
like come on in like
serve me when i was like my voice is
still cracking i'm like how could i get
a beer please like
it was just it was hilarious man i feel
like i was such a weird tall child
nothing like
that's crazy yeah they're not checking
they're not checking up there no no way
yeah if you're on a salmon boat
fishing i feel like wait yeah so yeah
can we take a can we take a tangent
about that real quick so you went salmon
fishing in the pacific ocean in the
north pacific ocean yeah that was my
that was my job for eight years that's
why i paid for uh vfx school was
catching fish oh
yeah it was a it was amazing it's a like
it was uh really was like my great
great grandparents great grandparents
did it and stuff and
came through uh my mom's side of the
family
um and then yeah my mom and dad were
like they met they met actually at film
school in vancouver and then um
my mom's parents they had their own
salmon fishing boat and
like wow yeah it was a lot of faces yeah
it was deep it was the whole whole
family like my aunt and uncle wait i'm
getting a lot here i'm getting i'm
getting fishing and film in the family
history yeah yeah for real it's that's
like the what the family does is like
film work most of it on set i'm the
first like vfx kid
um huh but yeah it was
it was kind of this weird thing of like
the fishing season uh was mostly just
like kind of from
uh like early
summer to kind of it usually ends around
like october something is different
depending on the fishery
but a lot of you know depending on you
know the fishing season some of them
would just like take the rest of the
year off because it was quite lucrative
back in the day but
um
like a couple of my uncles like they
worked on set and stuff my great uncle
hughes like did some producing and stuff
and it was just because vancouver was
such a big film industry and it was
really kind of blowing up yeah around
that time and so
i think there's some like
old commercial somewhere where it's like
my uncle on his fishing boat because
he's like i know a guy with a boat and
that's him like
yeah he was like an apple commercial or
something it's like when you had a hard
day held on the tack yeah you didn't
have to like pepperidge farmer members
yeah totally but yeah it was a man it
was cool
it kind of sucked because i didn't get a
lot of summers i was like
up like covered in fish blood and it was
like cold and wet
um but it was it was i no regrets like
it was um it was an amazing experience
and like
you know afforded me the opportunity to
go to a really great effects school and
i was like
by the like the end of high school i was
like bringing my laptop out there on the
boat and like working on little
animations wait wait i found
advil tv spot crossing the atlantic
oh i don't know i don't know i don't
know if you'd be able to find it but was
it like deadliest catch vibes
let me see not that insane because we're
on like smaller salmon boats but when
you're up north like off the coast of
alaska you'd hear those guys on the
radio and stuff and i love that show
girl wow and so you'd hear like i don't
know what was your name like screaming
for real you'd be like
i don't know it was one called like the
sea shepherd or something like you'd
hear those boats and you'd be like whoa
that's the celebrity boat
that's cool wow but yeah it was so cool
wait so there's like there's like a
culture amongst like your boat and like
what boat you're on oh yeah big time it
was like really yeah i mean i kind of i
was i was the last of my family to ever
take up the reins um yeah but it was
like man there was like a huge it was
like this big booming industry for a
while from all the stories i've like
been told and it was like the whole
thing you'd have like your crew like so
it'd be like my mom and dad had their
boat uh my mom's brother my uncle
michael he had his own boat
uh my great uncle jimmy he had his own
boat and then my man and opie my grandma
and grandpa they had their own boat and
they'd be like rolling in this crew with
like some of our family friends and
stuff and yeah
it was
uh it
it's a bit of a weird like i don't know
family history but it was uh it was
super cool and well that's a great way
to like make money in a particular
season and then be able to go off and
and do other things which i feel like is
very
i mean
yeah i feel like it's a lot of people
that ended up in that area
you know kind of where you're from like
that's that's part of the life it's like
you you weren't just
like working doing one thing you like a
lot of people those people were
living
you know
off the land off of what they could do
you know all that stuff yeah it's it's
pretty cool i mean like vancouver like
the west coast of canada is such an
amazing place it's um like you know a
lot of them once they got there uh
immigrating from different parts of the
world they're like well i'm not gonna
leave like this is amazing my yeah my
nana she always likes to say she didn't
go very far in life because she's like
now lives like 10 minutes from where she
was actually born like wow and yeah it's
just you know she she was it she i mean
still is till this day she's a total
badass like she captained her own fish
boat and stuff like that's awesome yeah
she's she's awesome but it was a
it's cool man it was uh you know they
would work like all summer and then my
parents especially they would just be
like ski bums during the winter
basically and like
yeah yeah it was a pretty cool pretty
cool do you like the
smell and taste of salmon after all
those years of
being around it i honestly love it oh
nice well that's great it's like my
favorite honestly it's it's one of those
things though i'm like so snobby about
it so i like never
i'll never order like so you you know
what good salmon is now that's so you're
you're cursed as well yeah
yeah it's um
it was it was always like really funny
because i would never order like seafood
out with friends or anything because i
was always like
got a freezer full at home
but yeah that is true though it's like
when you have any sort of standards of
expectation life is a little bit worse
in my opinion yeah it's kind of nice to
just be down for whatever the cheapest
wine on the menu just yes whatever
seriously i can't tell the difference
yeah thank you it's a it was such a cool
experience little man like i would like
i mean it was i think probably kept me
out of a lot of trouble because it was
like during the summers you know where
you get up to shenanigans and i would
just be out there working and it like i
would bring my i had like a little uh
sony handycam and i would like make
little films and stuff while i was
fishing and like i think you could
probably there's like one on vimeo
somewhere like me fishing when i'm like
a little nice we gotta we gotta find all
these we covered in facebook we got
fenner's fish boat
yeah uh i think it is on vimeo i'll find
that at some point
yeah it was cool it was like it's kind
of weird but it was like that's how i
learned to like edit in premiere and
stuff was like on my laptop on a fish
boat like just you must have a strong
stomach
oh dude yeah do not get seasick i don't
do you get sick from vr uh no no it's uh
like read it reading in cars whatever
i'm all good
that's incredible because yeah it was uh
it was like you'd i mean it was so funny
like you'd be doing wheel watches
because you'd have to run the boat like
overnight down from like uh we'd fish
off like southern tip of alaska kind of
thing and run it down to prince rupert
which is a town in northern bc like a
port where we'd unload fish
um yeah and so i'd like do a wheel watch
where it's like okay we'd leave the
fishing grounds at like you know 8 p.m
and maybe get into port like run all
night get in at like 6 a.m or something
and you take shifts watching you can't
really see anything but you're checking
the radar and stuff and i'd just be
sitting at the helm with my laptop like
working on music or like editing stuff
and i was like it's so funny to me like
that's why i like practiced vfx and
stuff
wow dude that's that's really epic man
like that's super cool it's such a great
way to like live free too you know like
you you do that part of the year and
then you work on sets part of the year
or like yeah that's just
what an experience yeah it was uh it was
really cool it's it's
one of those things i
like
during during covet i was like well if
the whole industry shuts down i'll just
go become a fisherman
yeah it was pretty cool
that's why i've never been to that
northern part of the pacific
it is uh is amazing man like especially
um
there's a haida gwaii uh also known as
like the queen charlotte islands is
it's also like the coast uh like
northern
island off the coast of canada yeah i'm
looking i'm looking at it on a map here
dude one of the most amazing places i've
ever been and we were lucky enough that
we would fish around there a lot and
it's just like
it's really crazy they have a lot of
like the indigenous like first nations
like you can still go find this remote
island with all like the old longhouses
and stuff still just there in the forest
and it's like it is crazy man like
not so much anymore but like my parents
would tell me stories they'd be walking
along and you'd find like skeletons and
stuff oh like it's like this crazy like
kind of untouched land i think it's a
lot different now because it's kind of a
lot of people know about it
yeah now that we know there's they've
cleaned the bones and bones yeah but it
was it was very very cool it's the yeah
it was you know
one one of those places that i would
love to go back to one day just uh to be
able to experience because we were i
mean i did get to experience it but a
lot of time we were working so you
didn't get to
go exploring as much but it's it's a
very very cool place that's awesome what
if they have a sign that says we're now
bone free
something like that
now now
yeah pretty much
family friendly and bone free
that's awesome
man that is cool
yeah that's like so far does anyone else
have a family history that's we don't
know about that we need to talk about
not on that level i mean that's like a
lineage of iron fisherman and you're
like secretly part of the royal family
yeah yeah we don't talk about that
they're lost they gave me my my uh my
dowry well i don't think that's the
right word whatever that is give him to
go away
i might be wrong about this people that
are really into like royal
and herald heraldry and stuff like that
might might be mad about this but i read
somewhere that there is some documented
justification to establish how queen
elizabeth is related to king david
huh
yeah i'm not familiar
i i'm very bad with with english history
i just think that it's funny that the
guards of the palace are called beef
eaters you know
that's enough for me
that's makes a good gin though what
you know so silly yeah they're called
bee feeders that's not very descriptive
so in a way we're all guards
do you think that's a tie a callback to
like when beef was like a hard thing to
get and like these guys were strong and
tough and so let's let's look this up
real quick i was kind of hoping i got my
things more like slang yeah there's like
a slang or like something you'd shout at
them when you're mad we actually talked
about this on the previous podcast
remember the feasting and the nights and
the largest nights it's more ham for the
night
yeah oh originally a derogatory term for
a well-fed servant
as much beef as they wanted from the
king's table henry the eighth everyone's
just loitering to get more beasts
he's like harold you've had enough
henry the seventh personal guards were
the first beef eaters
some beefy boys
it's such a weird insult so henry viii
told them to stay and guard the tower
permanently that's like that's like
that's like us going you know what
honestly we're hiring roto monkeys
you are an official
monkey
here's your title
and it's like okay stuff
yeah
it's like and here's your hat you have
to wear when you wrote a scope
because
you can't hear any emotions
yeah like it's a good thing that you're
a roto monkey it is yeah it's a funny
proud about being a roto monkey i mean
that's how the fighting irish of notre
dame got got started
because everyone was like
drunk irish people fighting yeah yeah
well it's kind of derogatory you know
for like a bunch of catholic kids be a
bunch of rowdy catholic kids the
fighting irish yeah that that one makes
more sense as being derogatory but like
beef eating
i guess i don't see the insult you know
i'm not seeing it back far enough like
look at you you're all well-fed well
they all come out of the king's court
you know going
yeah
[Music]
that was hard skeletal like
[Laughter]
back in the day that would have been
something that would have been very hard
to get yeah like the ability to eat beef
all the time the ability to be bloated a
buffet of beef
all you can eat all you can eat from the
king's table
only that's kind of all of the tables
are off limits yeah i know that's a
great perk unlimited beef if we can
institute that here if we just have the
king's table and it's just full of beef
i'll be a beefeater yeah all day i often
think about how
like if you were to go back in time like
500 years ago what the
if
if
at the time what they would give uh
sorry
i can't describe this very well
expiration dates on food you know like
how how much more lenient they people
were you know they're like
sometimes you know i make a salad and
the next day it's all dank like wet
you know and you're like and you're like
ugh but i'm like dude this is 500 years
ago i'd be like legit this would be
great still yeah man i feel like i'm
still that way i eat some like
i'm like leftovers i've been there for
two weeks i'm like i'll risk it like
no i i'm usually good on
some i mean yeah but yeah depends on how
good the salmon is oh dude i honestly i
think it comes from fishing because we'd
be out there and you go for like long
periods of time and so you'd be like
tasting the milk and it's like half sour
whatever i need it wow yeah
what one time how often do you guys stop
uh we
the first season or second season i
fished we were on a freezer boat so that
you're out there for like three weeks to
a month at a time
like out there away from yeah but then
most of the time when i was fishing with
my dad we had an ice fishing boat um so
then you do like
five days ten days max probably
yeah but the refrigeration was
lackluster like our uh our fish boat was
like an old wood uh salmon troller built
in like the 1950s like wow it was wooden
yeah yeah it was an old wooden boat it
was gonna last the wooden boats on the
coast it was super cool you've been out
on on those wild ocean waters
how the heck did the vikings do it on
those wooden boats dude like insane like
how terrifying yeah i mean we're we're
out there on like you know solid you
know i mean they're a wood boat but it's
like it's a solid boat um
and like even in like weather that's not
that crazy you're still terrified like
um dude like viking ships and stuff that
like that was insane yeah they went all
over the world on these little like
long did you just use like sun shadows
or something on a little device yeah or
something at least that's what the show
said the viking show so hopefully that's
yes because that was awesome literally
all i know
uh but yeah it's just wild to me that
people would go out in in a hunt for
gold like that that's the weirdest part
to to leave your land where you're
you're good you've got food you've got
shelter to get in a wooden boat go
across the ocean just trusting this rock
and shadow idea
to go get gold from other people that
you can't really even use at all
and bring it back
and then put it down they got to get
that king's beef too though that yeah
yeah
that that's worth dying for it was a
hard life though man you know like your
perspective would have been totally
different yeah it would have been
totally different and there's the
valhalla idea right the honorable way to
go is in combat or something like that
yeah so maybe the pursuit of that is
worth it too but finding new people to
fight yeah yeah
that's mostly their reasoning their
forest is full of bones still
it's not a bone freeze
well that that that is kind of that was
kind of built into their culture though
you know that was how like men
established themselves it was like
you l you were literally like okay how
many
towns have you raided how many
you know
how much gold have you taken how many
people have you killed like that that's
all part of the
that's wild
it's just it's it's kind of hard for us
to even fathom it just clean up
yeah
yeah
um
but yeah it's like dark souls it's
yeah
it's pretty much pretty much
just looking for more and more people to
fight more xp yeah more gold more
treasures
not too not to like totally stereotype
but like prison culture is a little bit
like that
and you can see it sometimes in like
gang culture and the way that it carries
over too
um but it's like you establish your it's
all about quote respect and quote honor
because there's hardly any of those two
quote things
um and so it's all like revolved around
like that whole muerta culture of like
you know you don't say it
upon el morta means like i
swear to be silent on pain of death
oh wow um yeah
[Laughter]
sorry that was kind of that was kind of
a tangent and it's interesting but man
and beef yo
so fenner you're going to have to take
us all out on a fishing boat man this
sounds like an epic adventure yes we can
simulate it line the couches up here
do you know
peter mckinnon yeah yeah he's a really
really well-known yeah canadian uh
creator he's done a bunch of stuff out
on
uh
like i don't know if he's on fishing
boats or what but he's got like shots of
whales and like shots of like icebergs
and like he's getting all kinds of crazy
photography out there and i don't know
where he's getting it but it's amazing
yeah we would man we'd see you see a lot
of whales and stuff like it was it was
amazing like uh this place called cape
shocking off the coast of alaska it's
like the northernmost
border of canada uh in alaska like we'd
be it's it was really funny we'd be
fishing in canadian waters and then at
night you'd go anchor up in the american
water so you'd have to call into the
coast guard every night and be like yo
can we stay here
yeah but man for like the last three
years of my dad and i fishing together
there was like this pod of humpback
whales that would be up there every
summer it was like seven or eight and
they do this crazy thing called bubble
feeding where you'll just be out on like
the back of the fish boat like checking
the lines and then you'll see this
massive bubble in the water and you're
like oh god and it's like it's a cthulhu
or something's gonna come up and all of
a sudden it's like seven or eight
humpback mouths will come up because
they basically trap all the krill in
these like bubble nets that they make
and then they just go straight up and
it's like this mountain coming out of
the water and it would just be
every day for like months uh for like
the last three years we fished it was
you're you're on a wooden fishing
yeah and i think sam
a salmon skimmer or whatever what did
you call it
go after the boat no but it's like
sometimes they come up and they're so
close so you're like oh man they like
did they almost hit us how long are
these boats how long are these salmon
boats i think our boat it was on the
smaller side i think it was like 40
i think it was like 46 feet i want to
say how big is one of those whales
yeah
that's where you're around the city
yeah yeah humpback
will like be the same size
it's probably about the same size
yeah
yeah for 49 to 50 feet and there's 47 to
52 feet yeah it's crazy you should look
up like bubble feeding home it looks
like so a whale comes up that's as long
as the boat that you're on yeah with
like their mouth
it's dude it's crazy
yeah if you look up bubble feeding it
looks like this demon coming up it's
just these mouths and they're i guess
they get all the water in they're gullet
or whatever so it's all stretched out it
looks like terrifying
i never like yeah i mean it looks like a
bunch of fish feeding at the surface but
they're just so big
yeah
it's and then there's they do it in like
in like patterns too
yeah yeah it's like they do like these
spiral patterns so it's super weird it's
like when you're out there and you've
been out there i don't know it got weird
like yeah
no joke yeah the ocean is is really
scary and i never used to find it scary
oh look at that yeah so yeah you'd just
be like fishing along the attack and
then you'd see something like that all
of a sudden you're like was it like a
demon coming up from the depths right
now so they all work together to like
spiral trap them in the bubble net yeah
it's so crazy like i watch a lot of uh
stuff like this with my kids because
they're like really into it and yeah
whales yeah and uh
dolphins both do really similar things
yeah um like dolphins
in like low uh like more shallow waters
they do the spiral but instead they uh
they basically kick up the sand yeah and
so instead of using bubbles to trap them
in they basically create like this like
sand vortex in the water
just like that and the exact same thing
happens
so cool yeah i'm pretty sure there's
only
a a certain pod of dolphins that know
how to hunt like that that at least
humans know about oh well they're like
the elite
maybe maybe it's the elite dolphin i
think i think i've seen i've seen what
you're talking about and it's
i think that's only been documented like
with that family of dolphins
i think yeah it's it's crazy man they're
they're so smart like we'd have uh i
guess an orca like a killer whale's
technically a dolphin they
like it's funny talking with my dad
about it and stuff he'd be like oh this
never used to happen but like when we
were fishing they got smart enough that
they knew they could go up and bite the
fish right off the line and they'd like
just bite them just shy of the head so
that they wouldn't get the hook on them
or anything and so wow yeah it was crazy
man like they just knew that they're
like oh there's fishing boats there
sweet free fish like that's
crazy it was yeah it was cool we uh wow
yeah i have like this very healthy fear
of the ocean yeah from fishing it's it's
funny too because like
my dad and i did the uh the cage diving
thing
in south africa for the great whites
yeah and uh you know i wasn't afraid of
the ocean at that point at all i just
thought it was really cool and
fascinating and i was really excited to
do it and they threw out a little foam
like seal shape thing onto the top of
the water we're just hanging out on the
boat just chatting and having a good
time and all of a sudden you hear like
the water get disturbed and i ran over
to the side and you literally see this
mouth like it was the craziest thing it
was like pitch black ocean and then just
this mouth come up out of the black and
just snap it in half dude and like so
violently rip it away and go down and it
was half gone
that i i immediately had this whole new
respect i mean i should have had it
before i went but but seeing that and
that wasn't even a big one that was like
a 13 and a half foot and i think they
get to like 20 plus feet or something
but uh the guy on the boat was saying
come winter time they go and chow down
on all the seals yeah that are going
through and he said on one trip he saw
five seals get eaten by great whites
that are just coming out and just
snapping their heads off and ripping
them to pieces and they come out of
nowhere and supposedly they they not
only can sense that you're in the water
and i could be wrong so shark people
correct me but they can like sense your
your like central nervous system the
electricity in it and they can see if
you're nervous like they sense that
you're nervous from way far away and
they'll take a bite just to like see
oh is this prey and they don't really
like to taste a human i don't think so
they'll leave you but you'll be one like
less
you know that's not really worth it so
if you're in the water you gotta be like
chill i guess i am so terrified of
sharks because of um another another
fishing story here
no fishing stories old fashion stories
podcast thank you this is great i didn't
expect it to go this direction and this
is great
so we we you'd work kind of crazy hours
my dad was great he'd let me sleep in
because i was a moody ass gangly
teenager boy
um and so he'd let me sleep in until
like 6 a.m so i'd like to get up and be
like half asleep and i remember one time
getting up and going i think it was
during uh i guess it's el nino or la
nina when the
water's all warm or something uh so they
were getting sharks up like off the
coast of alaska even um yeah and so i
went out to go pee over the side of the
boat and i looked down and this shark
swims right under where i'm peeing and i
was like
i was like obviously i was like oh my
god oh my god okay go pull the line in
and i pull in the line i'm like oh man
there's like a huge fish on this and it
was a big spring salmon uh like a
chinook i think they're called king
salmon in the states
um yeah but it's big and i'm like whoa
this thing's huge and i pull it in and
i'm like oh it's not that heavy though
and it's bitten clean in half and this
thing's like like this thick like the
size of my leg like and it was like
shark bite clean in half and i was like
okay it's freaky and ever since then i
am so scared of sharks like terrifying
how many will you do can we just change
the title quick to
fener peeing on a shark i was literally
about to say what percentage of people
[Laughter]
have peed on a live shark in the ocean
you might be the only one
i mean that's pretty cool
dude it was maybe that's the title yeah
it was a it's a very like it's one of
those memories i'm like does that did
that happen like yeah but like so bit
like this
big salmon and just bringing that in and
being like
oh that is bigger than my leg like yeah
it's just clean in half like it's like a
v-shaped bite and you're just like oh
it's like a generic shape bite mark yeah
yeah not even that big like i think it's
i think they're blue shark we've just
called them salmon sharks
um
maybe like maybe 10 feet maybe yeah i
don't i don't know though it's hard to
tell
yeah i mean and i don't i don't know
enough about the distinctions between
the different sharks to like have a good
understanding but went on another thing
with my dad and it was like you get in
with them i guess
and they're big and you don't see how
big they are until you get it off the
boat but you're out there with one guy
on a small boat and he says yeah it's
safe
and you don't know if he's right or not
and there's no insurance it's like just
a guy on a boat he's like yeah get in he
might be into that kind of thing like
watching people get eaten
and like i get into the water and i go
under and he starts throwing chum in or
whatever and they all start coming out
and there were probably like 15 20 of
them and they were all like six seven
eight feet long and i remember being
amongst them as they were like ripping
this thing to pieces thinking what am i
doing
and i felt like
i i come up for air because i'd like go
under with my little mask and he's
pointing like this he goes big
so one go back under and i look and it's
like swimming right at me it's like this
thick thing
and i just i remember a tiger shark it
was i don't know i don't know feeder
sharks it's a bee feeder yeah and i
remember it was it was my most
submissive moment of my life because i
just i just pressed myself gently
against the bottom of the boat
and i was like please don't
and it like swam right next to me to
where it's its side like slid against my
back and i just felt it like sliding
against my back as it went to the food
and i've never felt so vulnerable to
jordan that actually makes me like
nauseous yeah it was like i got ride in
the boat and we went home that's a great
note to wrap things up
get to that time guys
wow
they make diving suits or whatever that
like specifically do some weird like
electro magnetic something or another to
like mess with fish
like you're talking about the nervous
system stuff and like i feel like i saw
that i feel like i've heard about that
somewhere that would make sense it
sounds like how about just shark
resistance diving i've heard
i've just changed like no there's like
hunting gear that does that you know
there's like scent masking
but there's some stuff that also like
like messes with like either static or
electrical charges on your body too
that's cool help hide yourself better
that's very cool anti-shark bite
technology
is that where you're googling or what
you found steel
this literally is just chained
[Laughter]
so you don't get bit but you drown
[Laughter]
no it's lighter the chains are lighter
they're chains they're like mini
inflatable chains
hey
what's up could you place a sea shanty
oh do you know anything changes
oh man
there's a great sturgill simpson song
called uh what is it called stacey's
stories
now no
you and stacy i just i was it's always
my guess i hear she's got it going on
yeah she oh she does it's true no
unfortunately i don't know any c
chance off the top of my head
but uh i can make one up yeah
it's the best kind
um
[Laughter]
like heritage in this room
[Laughter]
[Music]
is there lyrics
i don't know could there be i was
on a
fenner woke up one morning and he had to
pee so he went outside and what did he
see he saw a shark
he had to pee
it was as long as his fishing boat was
did you think i was gonna say something
different i'm talking about
[Music]
all right thank you for joining the
corner cast everybody um
fenner thanks for being here man it's
good to finally have you down from the
land of canada and uh super excited for
what we're gonna be making here yeah man
i'm so stoked for uh what's gonna
be uh coming up here in the future yeah
hell yeah brother yeah yeah
brother
all right guys go eat some beef
beef time
tomorrow morning